[Music]
bruno mars and
anderson pack's new band silk sonic
showed up
and showed out at the grammys on sunday
performing their new single
leave the door open
last week after the initial list of
grammy performers was announced
mars posted an open letter to the
recording academy asking for a spot on
the show
quote if you can see it in your hearts
to allow two
out-of-work musicians to perform at your
show we would really appreciate it
and when it caught up with the show's
executive producer at rehearsals
he had this to say about the whole thing
they've been begging for a spot
and how is that felt to have bruno mars
groveling at your feet
i know he's well it's it's it's a lot of
pressure yeah
it's a lot of pressure when you know we
announced our lineup we thought everyone
was going to be happy and then bruno and
anderson pack are coming for us saying
you know why
why can't they get a slot you know what
i think we're gonna look at it
okay we're gonna look at it we're gonna
take a long hard look at it yeah
and there might just be time for a silk
sonic performance their first ever
performance as a duet
and the night's host trevor noah was all
for it
i've never been in a situation in life
where i've thought no
i can't squeeze bruno mars in that's all
i'm saying
as trevor noah i have no control over
the grammys i'm merely a host
and so i in my personal opinion would
always think if bruno mars ever said to
you
may i join your event you should just
say yes worst case scenario you have a
great time
best case scenario it makes the thing
even better you don't think there's
there's no it's like it's bruno mars
flash forward to sunday and mars took
the stage not once
but twice returning to the stage to pay
tribute to little richard
who died of bone cancer in may 2020 at
87 years old
[Music]
[Applause]
the 35 year old singer belted out a few
of little richard's classics like
good golly miss molly and long tall
sally
back in may following the news of
richard's death mars shared
this clip on instagram writing love you
little richard
as for mars there's more music on the
way with silk sonic
[Music]
the last album mars released was 24
karat magic
back in 2016. the album won seven grammy
awards including album of the year and
best r b album so when the grammy noms
were announced back in november
mars poked fun at his lack of nods and
new music
sharing this shot on instagram alongside
the caption
if you don't release music you can't
lose any grammys
hashtag think about it
you